Ich schan.
Guten Morgen. Ich heiße Seder Dortha. Ich bin auch der Station als Astetisch.
Ich möchte das Aufnahmigespräch mit den Durchführern sitzen, damit einverstanden.
Ja, gerne, natürlich. Hauptsache ein Doktor ist da. Ich habe so stark den Schmerzen.
Okay, dann können wir persönliche Daten anfangen, dann können wir weiter machen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Anne-Marie Seidel.
Bitte buchst du, probieren Sie langsam.
Anne-Marie ist mein Vorname. Anne und Marie, M-A-R-I-E.
Seidel, Siegfried, Emil, Ida, Dorra, Emil, Ludwig. Seidel.
Okay. Frau Seidel. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 53 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie geboren?
Oh, wann bin ich jetzt geboren? 1953, 1972, am 25. Februar.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich glaube, 1,65 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Mein Gewicht wissen. Mein Gewicht sind circa 70 kg.
70 kg. Okay. Und wie heißt Ihr Hausast?
Das ist die Franziska Müller.
Okay. Frau Seidel, was würdest du uns, was über Schweden haben Sie?
Ah, Herr Doktor, Entschuldigung, wie ist Ihr Name nochmal?
Sedat Ota.
Herr Ota.
Also ich habe seit heute Morgen sehr starke Oberbauchschmerzen hier oben.
Wie so ein bestrahlt wie ein Gürtel aus.
Okay.
Und das hat gestern Abend ganz leicht angefangen.
Ich habe mir jetzt nichts dabei gedacht.
Aber es ist heute Morgen so schlimm geworden.
Ich musste jetzt hier in den Krankenhaus kommen.
Sie haben eine sehr gute Entschuldigung getroffen.
Okay. Sie haben Oberbauchschmerzen.
Das ist Gürtel für mich geschmerzt.
Aber können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschrieben?
Sie sind bohrend, wellenförmig, belennend.
Also von allem ein bisschen.
Es ist eher so ein bisschen krampfartig und richtig starke Schmerzen.
Und was meint ihr, Sie sind starke?
Zum Beispiel auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, wobei Sie haben für 6 Tage Schmerzen.
Wie starke sind die Schmerzen?
Gestern Abend waren Sie vielleicht bei 2, 3.
Heute sind Sie schon bei 8, 9, würde ich sagen.
Ohne Medikamente wäre besser.
Aber wenn Sie nicht aushalten können,
können wir Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel geben.
Ja, das wäre mir sehr lieb.
Aber wenn die Untersuchungen jetzt nicht lange dauert,
kann ich auch kurz warten.
Ja, das wäre besser.
Okay. Vielen Dank.
Strahende Schmerzen aus.
Sie haben gesagt, die Gürtel für mich starren Sie in den Rücken?
Ja, also es fängt vorne hier an
und der Strahende ist so ein Gürtel so ein bisschen nach hinten.
Haben Sie die Schmerzen ständig oder gelähigendlich?
Nein, ich habe vor 2, 3 Jahren mal ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt.
Damals hat es geheißen, es sei die Gallenblase,
weil da habe ich auch so kleine Steine drin.
Aber jetzt ist es anders.
Jetzt sind die Schmerzen noch heftiger, noch schlimmer und noch schlimmer.
Okay.
Strahende Schmerzen sind plötzlich auf oder starren Sie langsam?
Also es ist gestern plötzlich aufgetreten
und ist jetzt heute Morgen ganz schlimm geworden.
Gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen verbessert oder verschlimmert?
Zum Beispiel Körperhaltung, Essen, Bewegung?
Nein, bisher nicht. Das wird immer noch schlimmer.
Haben Sie auch andere Begräßbeschwerden,
zum Beispiel Übelkeit, Müdigkeit, Erbruchung?
Erbrechen noch nicht, aber so eine starke Übelkeit manchmal.
Ein, zwei Mal hatte ich auch ein Brechereiz,
wo ich das Gefühl hatte, ich muss jetzt erbrechen.
Müssen Sie auf aufschlossen?
Ja.
Falls sei denn, haben Sie auch Sortbrennen?
Eigentlich gar nicht so, nein.
Okay.
Füllen Sie sich über Blät oder haben Sie voller Gefühl?
Das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, nein.
Falls sei denn, haben Sie manchmal das Gefühl,
dass Sie so toilette müssen, aber da kommt eigentlich nichts?
Nein, nein.
Und wann hatten Sie die letzte Magen- oder Darmspiegel?
Aber bisher noch gar keine.
Leiden Sie uns, Luftnot?
Luftnot, nein.
Ist denn ein Herzrasen, Herzkuloffen oder Herzstöpeln bemerkt?
Ob ich bemerkt habe, nein.
Falls sei denn, haben Sie viel bei Stufhors oder nach Schweiß?
Wie jetzt?
Meinen Sie das, ob ich das jetzt hatte oder irgendwann mal?
Jetzt oder in der letzter Seite, meine ich.
Ach so, nein.
Und haben Sie ungewollt ab oder zugenommen?
Nein, ich bin immer ungefähr bei 70 Kilo.
Ich verstehe.
Und hat Sie Ihre Appartition verändert?
Mein Appetit, nein, der ist zu gut, leider, nein.
Besuchen Sie regelmäßig Ihre Frauenarzt?
Ja, schon, aber ich war jetzt in den letzten 34 Jahren nicht beim Frauenarzt.
Ich habe auch jetzt keine Beschwerden.
Mit Ihrer Periode ist alles in Urbahn?
Also mit 60 oder mit 53, ich habe jetzt seit einigen Jahren schon in der Männerpause, da habe ich jetzt kein Problem.
Und treibungsregelmäßig Sport?
Ich würde gerne, aber eigentlich nicht.
Ja, ich möchte.
Ich würde über Vorerkrankungen sprechen.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie hatten Stein im Gallenblase.
Ja.
Gibt es noch andere Vorerkrankungen, wenn wir Ihnen?
Ich hatte mal als junges Mädchen mal eine Blinddarmentzündung, das ist operiert worden.
Meine Mandeln sind auch raus.
Und ich hatte zwei Kaiserschnitzel.
Und wann waren die so fast schon?
Sie haben gesagt, ich habe diese Benitrieren-Infrosion mit Mandelpositionen.
Ich glaube, ich habe 15 Jahre, glaube ich.
Mandelpositionen?
Und die Fahrseite leiten Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Ich nehme keine Medikamente, ist mir nichts bekannt.
Was meinen chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ich meine Bruthochdruck, Magen, Leber, Herzerkrankungen, ansteckende Erkrankungen.
Nein, glücklicherweise habe ich da bis auf die Gallenblase nichts gehabt.
Und dieser Gallenblase Stein, wann war das genau vor zwei Jahren?
Das war kurz nach meinem 50. Geburtstag.
Laufstelle diskutiert es nach dem OP?
Also seitdem, ich habe keine Operation gehabt, ich habe der ganze Gallenblase ist noch drin.
Ja, festgestellt und keine Operation?
Damals, Infusionen bekommen Schmerzen, mit Lunder war das auch relativ schnell wieder weg.
Ich wollte keine Operation.
Die Ärzte wollten unbedingt operieren, aber ich wollte nicht.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und Fahrseite haben Sie Allergien oder Unverzweckigkeiten?
Ich habe nur Polenallergie, nein.
Und wie äußert sich das?
Ja, meine Nase läuft, ich kriege Tränen in der Augen, aber da habe ich ein gutes Medikament.
Der SIFT-Nieber wird es gut.
Das nehme ich während.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und nur um Frühlingswälder?
Ja, nur in den ersten, dreimal, zwei Monaten.
Und Fahrseite, raufen Sie?
Ja.
Wie viel und seit wann raufen Sie?
Oh je, das würde schon länger.
Ich sauge seit meinem dreißigsten Lebensjahr.
Und einschachtel pro Tag, oder?
Ja, jetzt nicht mehr, so viel.
Früher habe ich viel mehr geraucht, aber jetzt ungefähr eine halbe Schachtel.
Okay, drücken Sie Alkohol?
Selten, eigentlich fast nicht.
Also können wir sagen, ein Gläser war ein paar Wochen, oder?
Nur wenn es ein Fest- oder Geburtstag ist.
Aber hause trinke ich eigentlich fast nie Alkohol.
Okay.
Und ich möchte betonen, dass das eine Routinefrage ist.
Bitte nehmen Sie das nicht persönlich.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen oder andere Substanzen?
Drogen, nein.
Das waren wir.
Früher in der Studentenzeit haben wir gerne mal Gläser geraucht,
aber trotz nicht.
Okay, verstehe.
Ja, Frazer, gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, meinen Vater hatte einen hohen Blutdruck.
Er hatte auch einen normalen Herzinfarkt mal gehabt.
Und dann war irgendwas mit der Prostata, glaube ich, aber mehr weiß ich leider nicht.
In meinem Mutter hatten Diabetes, aber das hat sie ganz gut im Griff.
Und ich glaube, sie hatte Myome, so dass man die Gebärmutter operieren musste.
Okay.
Und wie heißt der Vater und Mutter jetzt?
Mein Vater ist leider vor zwei Jahren verstorben.
Mein Mutter ist 75.
Ist der an Herzkrankheiten verstorben?
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Die Herzen haben gemeint, dass er an so einem plötzlichen Herz tot.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwisterfaseile?
Ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Ist der gesund?
Ja, der ist jünger als ich.
Der ist, ich glaube, so circa 45.
Der ist topfitiert, macht Sport, raucht nicht, hat kein Alkohol.
Also, der ist sportlich, ist kerngesund.
Ja, ich misste.
Frazer, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie hatten zwei Kreiserschinete.
Und wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Ich habe drei Kinder, eine Totsche und zwei Söhne.
Sehen Sie gesund?
Ja, ich habe Glück, ich habe eine Weise.
Ich habe die Kinder in der Skurz gehabt.
Ja, das ist ein Wunder.
Und was ist Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Juristin.
Könntest du wiederholen, bitte?
Eine Juristin, rechts anbieten.
Ja, rechts anbieten.
Ja.
Okay, wie frechst du?
Ich habe Richterin gearbeitet, das seit zwei, drei Jahren habe ich mich aber jetzt als Anwalt niedergelassen.
Und habe eine eigene Kanzlei.
Okay.
Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen über Ihr Habbeschwerden.
Vorseite haben Sie Hautverfärbungen bemerkt, zum Beispiel um die Nagel oder an den Flanken.
Hautverfärbungen?
Nein, ich meine ich auch.
Geröne oder braunliche Verfärbungen?
Nein, nein, ich bin nicht aufgefallen.
Wieso fragen Sie das?
Was ist das?
Barspeicherltyrosis, manchmal sehen wir diese Verfärbungen.
Nein, habe ich jetzt nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Vorseite, das waren meine Fragen zu Ihrem Beschweden.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ich würde mich sehr dankbar, wenn Sie herausfinden, was das ist und dass die Schmerzen besser werden.
Ja, okay.
Dann, zuerst wollen wir die köpelische Untersuchung durchführen, die Blutabnehmen, vielleicht auch durch das Schall.
Dann werde ich mit dem Oberhass besprechen, danach melde ich mich bei Ihnen und warum ich weiter.
Das machen Sie alles noch heute oder?
Ja, wir müssen heute machen.
Okay, das ist gut. Wunderbar. Vielen Dank.
Gerne, gute Besorgung.
Vielen Dank. Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Der Doktor hat es so gut gemacht, die anderen Kollegen wollen nichts mehr fragen.
Keiner traut sich.
Birin und Stuhl, ein paar Veränderungen hat er gefragt?
Nein, hat nicht Stuhlveränderung, hat nicht Hautveränderung.
Und Augen zum Beispiel, nicht gefragt?
Augen auch nicht gefragt, ja, nicht Augen, Augen.
Aber Doktor hat es ja gesehen, dass die Augen in Ordnung sind.
Die Fragen nach ich habe es gestellt.
Sehr gut, Herr Doktor. Ein Kardiolobe muss den anderen Kollegen erklären, was gefällt hat, der auch Merksam.
Herr Doktor Sedat, was sind Sie für den Facharzt?
Ich bin Allgemeinmediziner.
Können wir anfangen, Sedat, heute haben wir keine Zeit, deswegen?
Okay, ich kann das spontan machen.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag Frau Oberast, wir haben eine neue Patientin, Frau Anmeris-Seiden.
Ich würde gerne über Sie berichten, darf ich, haben Sie Zeit?
Vielleicht in einer halben Stunde, ich habe einen Moment, wo Sie sich selbst eine Patientin angucken, aber ist das was Dringendes?
Was hat Sie denn erzählt?
Ich denke, ich habe verdattet, ich habe es schon kreativ.
Oh, das ist was Akutes, erzählen Sie bitte, was hat Sie denn?
Okay, Frau Seidel ist eine 35-jährige Patientin.
Wie viel?
53-jährige.
Ah, eine 53-jährige Patientin, okay.
Sie ist 1,65 m und 60 kg groß und 70 kg.
Sie stellt sich mit seit morgen bestehenden Gürtelformigen, krampfartigen, epigastische Schmerzen.
Desweiteren klagt sie über Naja.
Hat sie die 1. Zeit heute Morgen die Schmerzen oder geht es schon länger?
Gestern Abend hat sie die Schmerzen und die Schmerzen ist der progressive Schmerz.
Bedehend.
Ja, in Laufers Zeit zu nehmen die Schmerzen.
Seit heute Morgen sind die Schmerzen zunehmend, aber die Schmerzen begannen gestern schon.
Ja, und sie strahlen in Dorsal, in Rückenstrahlen der Schmerzen.
Sie sind guter für mich und sie haben kein Fieber, operativ ist gut, in Wechseljahren seit 3 Jahren.
Zustatt nach Appendectomie mit 15 Jahren und Mandeloper auch.
Also eine Tonselektomie.
Ja, Tonselektomie, ja genau.
Okay.
Außerdem hat sie 2 Kaiser-Schnitte.
2 Kaiser-Schnitte, okay, ja.
Und vor 2 Jahren, seit 2 Jahren hat sie Scholellithiliasis, aber das ist kontrolliert, er hat noch nicht operiert.
Wieso?
Er, ich dachte, ist jetzt eine Patientin.
Ja, sie ist noch nicht operiert.
Sie ist noch nicht operiert, nicht hart.
Ja.
Also, vor 2 Jahren hat man Galenblasensteine festgestellt, aber das ist nicht operiert.
Hatte sie eine Klinik oder Beschwerden und wie kam es dazu?
Sie wollte keine Operationen, erster empfehlen, aber sie ist dagegen.
Was hat sie für Beschwerden gehabt vor 2, 3 Jahren?
Er hat gesagt, sie hat dann ähnliche Beschwerden, aber jetzt, jetzt die Schmerzen ist viel stärker und...
Intensiver.
Ja.
Okay, das heißt, es war kein Zufall, sondern sie hatte eine Klinik und auch Schmerzen damals schon.
Okay.
Polarnellergie ist bekannt und ausser sich als Konjektivitis.
Rekordzune wurde mit 15 Fakunzieher beacht.
Alkoholkonsum wurde mit nur Feiertags oder Geburtstags beacht.
In Familienarbeiter, Vater ist an die Newcastle Infactus verstobene.
Er hat auch Arterielle Hypertonie und Beninprostate Hypopilasi.
Demutos sieben und fünfzig Jahre old, leidet an...
Die Mutter ist 57 Jahre alt.
Es kann bis zu schlecht sein. Wenn die Patientin 53 Jahre alt ist, dann ist doch die Mutter nicht 57 Jahre alt.
Sie meinen 75.
Ich denke auch, ich glaube, ich habe fast gehört.
Oh Herr Doktor, Sie müssen noch ein bisschen genauer hinhören.
Solche Fehler dürfen nicht passieren.
Die Mutter ist 75 wahrscheinlich.
Ja, ja. Leider dann der Betreffendtus zu zwei.
Und die Mutter ist die Operation.
Wer die Mutter, oder die Mutter, von wem berichten Sie jetzt?
Die Mutter.
Das muss ich dazu sagen.
Und die Bruder ist gesund und 45 Jahre alt.
Sie hat einen Bruder?
Ja, einer Bruder und sonst keine Geschwister.
Sie ist verheiratet, hat drei Kinder, arbeitet als Rechtsanwaltin.
Ja, das ist der Fall.
Okay, was ist hier für das derzeitlose Doktor?
Der Name ist auch Pankratitis.
Und aus welchen Genese heraus?
Das ist typische Klinik und wird guter vom Iggy Oberbauchschmerzen.
Was kann die Ursache dafür sein?
Normalerweise würde ich sagen Alkoholkonsum, aber Sie trinken welchen Alkohol?
Aber Sie ist Juristin, wir haben natürlich viel Stress, aber gut,
Sie hat es glaubhaft verneint, dass sie wohl trinkt.
Was meinen Sie? Warum hat sie jetzt eine Pankratitis?
Vielleicht raufen ist auch eine Risikofakte, sie rauft.
Sie braucht jetzt schon eine halbe Packung, aber ich glaube, das ist weniger.
Sie haben doch vorhin was gesagt, Sie hatten vor zwei, drei Jahren eine Vorerkrankung.
Ja, schon in Thersis.
Ein so?
Ein Stein, ein Stein könnte im Gallenweg liegen und diese werden verursacht.
Was machen Sie für Untersuchungen?
Ich höre für Untersuchungen, ich muss testen, Zypherrectoris oder gelbische Haltverfärbung.
Dunkelhaarurien muss ich fragen oder Strateure.
Welche Diagnostik machen Sie noch?
Hatte Sie sie neben Blut ab, haben Sie gesagt?
Wir nehmen Blut, Kursesblut, Insündungsparameter, Pankreas-Werte wie Amylas und Lipas, Leberwerte,
Scholesterswerte wie Gamma-Gete, Alkalische-Fosforters und Pylirvin.
Wir können jetzt Muskellen-Süme kontrollieren und eine EKG schreiben,
als Differenzialdiagnostik für Akutkonenszentrum.
Differenzialdiagnosen, okay, wir sind jetzt Differenzialdiagnosen.
Welche Differenzialdiagnosen denken Sie noch?
Akutkonenszentrum sein und er hat schon Stein in Gallenblässe, das war in der Schule.
Er oder Sie?
Sie, ich sage immer.
Haben Sie was gegen's Doktor oder was ist Ihr Problem?
Das war ein Scholesostitis.
Was kann noch so ein Problem?
Magengeschwöre oder Gastrofagia-Reflexkrankheit.
Eine Reflexerkrankung, okay.
Was noch?
Ich habe vorhin irgendwas vom Herz gesprochen.
Was heißt das jetzt?
Was kann es sein?
Immer denken wir, solche Oberborgschen-Märzen haben Sie schon ein EKG geschrieben.
Und wie ist da was Auffälliges?
Mein sehr Herzmuskellen-Süme?
Herzmuskellen-Süme oder eine Herzinfarkt?
Oder EKG-Ergäte?
Wir sind doch jetzt bei den Differenzialdiagnosen.
Bei EKG sehen wir ST-Herbungen.
Er verlust oder negativät T-Wähle.
Hat die Patientin irgendetwas?
EKG war unauffällig.
Aber sie müssen differenzial diagnostisch auch an einen Herzinfarkt denken.
Woran denken Sie noch?
Woran müssen Sie noch überlegen?
Vielleicht können Sie Kollegen ein bisschen helfen.
Der Herr Doktor ist ein bisschen nervös.
Wer kann noch helfen?
Welche Differenzialdiagnosen muss ich mit jetzt bedenken?
Was haben wir da noch?
Und was läuft unter den Pankreers?
Ein großes Gefäß.
Die Sektion.
Da ist ein großer Abteil im Bauch.
Woran muss man noch denken?
Was ist noch außer Pankreers im Bauch?
Die anderen Kollegen können alles ruhig helfen.
Woran müssen Sie noch denken?
Achutes Abdomen?
Will kein Arzt helfen.
Was ist das für ein Akutaschub?
Ist da was bekannt?
Haben Sie gefragt?
Ich habe vorher Akutaschub angefragt.
Nein, das ist nicht bekannt.
Alles klar.
Was ist das für ein Akutaschub?
Ich habe es nicht bekannt.
Es ist nicht bekannt.
Okay, alles klar.
Wir haben zumindest schon mal nachgefragt.
Aber so etwas müssen Sie denken.
Haben die anderen Kollegen noch weitere Vorschläge?
Empfehlungen?
Was geben Sie für Schmerzen?
Welche Medikamente?
Wir geben keine Morphine gegen diese schmusskölige Kontraktion neben Wicke.
Aber was machen die?
Sie hat Schmerzen in den Patienten, was machen sie mit ihr?
Wir geben Schmerzbeteil natürlich, aber wir können das nicht mehr machen.
Sie hat doch Übelkeit, wollen Sie nicht lieber eine Infusion geben?
Ja, es wäre besser durch eine Wienersgatt.
Genau, also eine intrawende.
Wir müssen auch Nadel und Alkohol verändern.
Genau, das heißt, sie braucht einen Nadel, einen Zugang, sie machen Pionen.
Und welche Schmerzmittel gibt man als Erstes, was man versuchen würde?
Wir sind noch allgemein Mediziner, was geben Sie denn?
Oh, gleich, ja, Dramatur, aber man kann erst mal mit Novalgin zum Beispiel probieren, oder?
Ja, Novalgin kann er.
Wenn das nicht reicht, was kommt dann?
Ich bin allgemein Mediziner, ich habe noch gut gearbeitet.
Sie müssen es doch wissen, als Allgemeinmediziner, die Patienten haben Schmerzen,
die ja behandeln, mein Gott.
Herr Doktor, Herr Doktor, oh, ich glaube, mit der Prüfung bezahlt nichts.
Also, da kommt schon die Vorschläge, da sind Kolleginnen, die helfen,
Tramal kann man geben, Thylidin kann man geben, Prämiet kann man geben,
Vielflüssigkeit kann man geben, was kann man gegen die Krämpfe,
Buscopane kann man zum Beispiel geben, was kann man noch geben,
Säureblocker, Protonempumpenhämmer, PPI's, sie hat ja Oberbauchschmerzen, das kann man geben.
Also, da kann man noch einiges geben, Herr Doktor.
Und als Allgemeinmediziner sollten Sie das eigentlich ganz gut wissen.
Ah ja, das müssen wir uns überlegen, ob sich die Prüfung so bestehen, ich weiß nicht.
Okay, sollen wir hier kurz einen Pumpen machen, Herr Doktor, mal kurz.
Leste Simulation, Dr. Sedat eine Kolei-Liteasis.
Heute akut Pankratitis.
Deswegen, Sedat ist nicht bestand heute die Prüfung.
Sedat war eigentlich, ich habe ihn ein bisschen nervös gemacht, Sedat.
Ja.
Aber, das ist eine Simulation, der sollte Prüfung simulieren.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt ein bisschen streng.
Aber, diese Aussage, ich bin Allgemeinmediziner, ich weiß es nicht, das darfst du nicht sagen.